Please. Put yourself down.
Thank you. Oh, wow.
(AUDIENCE CHEERS)
What a crowd.
Thank you very much. I--
WOMAN: I love you, Bill!
Of course I love it,
I'm in show business.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
(LAUGHS)
But let's get to--
There's so much news.
I mean, if it's a week,
and it is a week,
there has to be, and there was,
more departures of key people
from the White House. Uh...
First one this week,
his lead lawyer,
Trump's lead lawyer
on the Russia investigation,
John Dowd.
I didn't even have him
in my bracket!
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
Uh... (LAUGHS)
But he's gone, and then,
Trump's second national security
advisor, H.R. McMaster...
(SCATTERED LAUGHTER)
He's out, and John Bolton is in.
Remember John Bolton?
Yes, you remember him as the...
-(AUDIENCE BOOS)
-(LAUGHS)
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
...ambassador to the U.N.
for George W. Bush.
So, he has experience
with incompetence.
-(LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE)
-Uh.. And... You know, he's...
He's been here.
John Bolton came here,
we talked to him.
He's another one of those hawks,
those super-militaristic hawks
who never served in Vietnam.
The only person, by the way,
in military history
who was classified 4F
because of his mustache.
-(LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE)
-That's... very rare. (LAUGHS)
He was...
But you know, he was
all gung-ho, John Bolton was,
for the war in Iraq.
Wants, now, to mix it up
big-time with Iran
and North Korea.
He's what they call
"an asshole's asshole."
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
-Uh...
And you'll ne-- (LAUGHS)
You'll never guess where
he has been working
for the last ten years.
-Fox News. Who guessed it?
I can't even...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
Or, as Trump calls it,
"the Home Shopping Channel."
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
-What the fuck is with this...?
-(APPLAUSE)
Meanwhile... (LAUGHS)
Meanwhile, I love this story,
housing secretary Ben Carson
said that he needed to spend
131,000 dollars
of tax-payer money...
Or maybe it's 31,000 dollars.
-Well, it's too much money.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
Tax-payer money
for a dining-room set
for his office,
because he said the old table,
these were his words,
was "actually dangerous."
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
You mean,
compared to John Bolton?
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
-Dangerous? I mean...
So, come on,
let's not bury the lead,
let's get to what people
are really thinking about.
Everyone is pissed off
at Facebook, right?
(AUDIENCE CHEERS)
We may have to go back to
boring each other face-to-face.
-This is serious, people!
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
Facebook got caught sharing
private data with people
who were using it to help elect
Donald Trump.
And users say
this is the worst thing
to happen on Facebook
since their mom sent them
a friend request.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
-This is...
-(APPLAUSE)
No. There's a hashtag
"Delete Fa..."
People are deleting
their accounts. Cher did it!
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
I mean, what's gonna happen?
If you don't post 88 pictures
of your toddler,
how will I know that you've
stopped having sex?
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
Don't worry.
Mark Zuckerberg, he's on it,
he's gonna crack down, he said.
Oh, yeah, he's gonna crack down.
Of course, he said that before,
but he is so determined
that we take him seriously
this time
that he promised to stop
dressing like a 12-year-old.
-So, I--
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
-That... He... (LAUGHS)
-(APPLAUSE)
Oh, and...
I must parenthetically say,
speaking of 12-year-olds,
you know, one thing
I love about America...
If I had to use one word
for America, I would say,
"mature."
Very mature,
this country, right?
I think "maturity."
Okay, well, add to that file
this week, in the maturity case,
the former vice president
of the United States...
and the current president
of the United States... (LAUGHS)
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
...threatened to
fight each other.
Two septuagenarians.
Joe Biden, did you see?
He said,
[IMPERSONATING BIDEN]
"If I was in High School now,
I'd take Trump behind the gym
and beat the hell out of him."
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
And then trump tweeted back,
[IMPERSONATING TRUMP]
"Biden would go down
fast and hard,
crying all the way."
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
(CHUCKLES)
And then the vice principal
came by and said, "Where are
you two supposed to be?"
(LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE)
It's a dream, right?
It's not really happening.
-(APPLAUSE CONTINUES)
-Okay...
Anyway...
what happened with Facebook
is they let a company,
Cambridge Analytica, mine data
from 50 million users,
and they used it to build
what they call
"psycho-graphic profiles"
of potential Trump voters.
That's who they were after.
So they were trying to find out
all this information.
They wanted to know
where they lived,
what kind of car they drove,
-what books they like to burn...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
Uh... All I know is they'd
better fix this shit quick.
-(SCATTERED LAUGHTER)
-(CHUCKLES)
Because Facebook is a great way
to go online and check out
your old girlfriends.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
Like Trump does with Pornhub.
(CHEERING AND APPLAUSE)
Oh. Oh.
(CHUCKLES) Oh. Oh, yes,
let's see what went on
in this weeks episode
of Restoring Honor and Dignity.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
Okay, this is-- There's so much.
First, there's a former
Apprentice contestant who says
she was the victim of Trump's
unwanted sexual advances.
She's suing him.
Playboy center-fold
Karen McDougal
said they had an affair.
She's suing to tell her story.
And of course,
porn star Stormy Daniels
revealed a lie-detector test
this week about the time
she was fucking Trump,
and passed the test.
It also came out this week
that Don Jr., apparently,
having an affair
with an Apprentice contestant.
This must be the breakdown
of the family
that conservatives warned about
if we allowed gay marriage.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
-Don't you think this...?
I think this is what they meant.
-(CHEERING AND APPLAUSE)
-Uh...
And, you know,
in the Don Jr. case, his wife--
Allegedly.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
His wife allegedly found out
about the affair because--
Listen to this, so cliche.
She checked his phone
when he was in the shower.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
And one of the texts said,
"We can't keep meeting
like this."
Turns out, that was
from the Russians. But it--
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
-It's all.. (CHUCKLES)
-(APPLAUSE)
-Anyway, this...
Did you see--?
Now, Karen McDougal,
the Playboy Playmate,
went on Anderson Cooper
last night and talked about--
She had a ten-month affair,
had, apparently, sex,
she said, dozens of times
with Donald Trump.
Always the same.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
Was always the same:
"Yes, Donald.
You're so big, Donald."
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
"I love you, Donald."
Then she would talk.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
-(BILL LAUGHS)
(CHEERING AND APPLAUSE)
But... No,
there was a poignant moment.
Karen McDougal,
she said she was-- (CHUCKLES)
She said she was sorry
for what she did to the other
woman in the equation.
But Ivanka said, it's okay,
she forgives.
-(LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE)
-Uh... (LAUGHS)
And... (LAUGHS)
And someone asked Trump
about Karen McDougal today.
They asked if they had
unprotected sex.
And he said, "No, we had
a non-disclosure agreement."
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
And... But what we're all
waiting for, right, Sunday?
60 Minutes?
Stormy Daniels is on 60 Minutes.
-(CHEERING AND APPLAUSE)
-I can't wait.
And... Stormy says
she is not gonna go
into details
about sex with Donald Trump.
She's saving that
for another show: 60 Seconds.